voici la scène de crime la chambre à
coucher
une violente dispute éclate vers 3h du
matin entre les deux ex et poux l'homme
saisit un couteau et frappe
sur le téléviseur une ligne de coque
c'est tout ce qui reste de ces deux
tubes vides le couple était sous
l'emprise de la drogue
[Musique]
atterrissage à Rio 11h30 de vol 32
degrés au sol et du soleil sur la carte
postale
Rio sont carnaval c'est plage sa musique
un rêve de touristes
sous la protection du Christ on dirait
qu'il plane sur la ville
Rio et ses 12 millions d'habitants les
cariocas
beaucoup de misères et quelques
millionnaires
on les trouve en bord de mer bien à
l'abri dans des villes à chic au centre
une forêt de building le quartier des
affaires
tout autour des bidonvilles les favelas
il y en a plus de 1000 disséminés sur
les hauteurs à Rio les pauvres ont vu
sur la baie
mais la violence gâche le tableau il y a
25 fois plus d'homicide qu'en France
en juin Rio va faire vibrer le monde du
foot 400 stars du ballon et 2 milliards
de téléspectateurs mais le soir après le
coup de sifflet final les armes
vont-elles parler pour éviter que la
fête soit gâchée le gouvernement employé
la manière forte il a envoyé l'armée
nettoyé les abords des stades mais cela
suffira-t-il pour plonger dans les
profondeurs de la ville je vais suivre
des journalistes de faits divers
avec eux je partirai sur une scène de
crime dans les beaux quartiers
j'irai voir un match au Maracana mais
côté caméra de sécurité
j'essaierai de comprendre le quotidien
d'une favela
et je ferai une balade en mer sur le
yacht d'un millionnaire
je verrai son ex-femme une ancienne
actrice jouer à l'exorciste
j'assistrais un procès et un enterrement
procédé un tueur à gage enterrement
d'une vieille dame tuée d'une balle
perdue en pleine église bienvenue à Rio
la cité merveilleuse avec en poche un
passeport pour le crime
[Musique]
à l'étranger comme en France je commence
mes journées par une revue de presse
en un coup d'œil on voit tout de suite
qu'ici le foot est roi il fait la une en
bonne place l'effet divers pas de photos
sanguinolente le traitement est plutôt
sobre
j'ai rendez-vous à la police judiciaire
division des homicides
allez prise de service il est 8 heures
du matin on signale déjà un homme tué
par balle
pas le temps de s'attarder direction le
blog le quartier le plus chic de la
ville
le corps a été recouvert d'une bâche les
télévisions ont été alertés par qui
elles sont arrivées avant la PJ
plateau en direct à deux mètres du
cadavre impensable en France
il y a deux hypothèses en vérité soit le
policier attiré pour se défendre sur le
petit laveur de voiture
la victime a été abattue par la police
légitime défense ou bavure
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
je viens de parler avec un commissaire
de la police criminelle un petit laveur
de voiture a tenté d'escroquer un
automobiliste
l'automobiliste refusait de payer
alors le jeune s'est énervé
un autre laveur de voiture est venu lui
prêter main forte les deux étaient armés
de tesson de bouteille le policier
aurait tiré et lundi 2 est mort
le policier était hors service habillé
en civile et ce n'est pas n'importe qui
il appartient aux forces spéciales pour
la crime l'enquête s'annonce délicate
ce sera le travail de Luciana
un physique de cinéma mais une carrière
déjà longue
le policier auteur des tirs a été emmené
au commissariat il a eu le temps
d'appeler l'Inde ses collègues le voici
lui n'a rien vu il veut t'aider Luciana
et peut-être aussi l'influencé
la victime n'était pas dans son état
normal
il termine un tesson de bouteille
mon collègue lui a tiré deux fois dans
les jambes et ensuite il a dû viser la
poitrine
pour un policier d'enquêter sur un
collègue le tout sous le regard de la
presse
[Musique]
ce n'est pas parce que c'est un policier
qui est impliqué ou que la presse est là
que cette affaire a plus d'importance
s'il y a une certaine pression oui il y
en a mais c'est normal
et ce n'est pas parce que c'est sensible
que ça change
bon bien sûr une affaire médiatique doit
être traitée le plus rapidement possible
c'est mieux
la pollutionifique arrive à son tour le
périmètre est enfin bouclé 3 heures
après le crime
les curieux ont eu tout le temps
d'observer sous tous les angles ce
spectacle morbide
des indices ont peut-être disparu
sur le trottoir du verre brisé
des douilles
du sang
le coronaire se repasse déjà le film du
meurtre il s'appelle Fernando Aires et
lui aussi pourrait tourner dans une
telle nouvelle il est pourtant en
docteur en médecine et ne laisse rien au
hasard
la main est encore souple la mort est
toute récente
la blessure est béante le superflic
attiré avec son 9 mm mais à quelle
distance et sous quel angle
voilà le trou regarde les bords regarde
ça ça a été fracturé
plus tard le légiste aura son bistouri
sur l'autre toit il va se servir d'un
coton-tige il explore l'intérieur de la
blessure
et lui il avait un couteau
de bouteille
encore une heure d'examen de la scène de
crime et les brancardiers de la morgue
évacuent enfin le corps
soudain décrit au bout de la rue la
nouvelle s'est répandue comme une
traînée de poudre
la police aurait commis une nouvelle
bavure
n'aime je te vois je te vois monte ma
tête et tu verras si je te retrouve
apparemment tout le monde n'a pas
confiance dans la police à Rio bavure ou
pas Fernando le médecin légiste a déjà
sa petite idée
quels sont les premières constatations
d'après ce que vous voyez de la position
du corps et des balles les premiers tirs
l'ont atteint près de l'arbre
[Musique]
une fois par terre il est encore été
touché par plusieurs tirs à courte
distance
n'est pas en faveur de l'homme qui a
tiré franchise étonnante devant un
journaliste avant même d'en référer à
ses supérieurs il y aurait bien eu
bavure le superflic aurait tiré à bout
portant sur un homme à terre la légitime
défense ne tiendrait pas
l'inspectrice ou Tiana n'est pas au bout
de ses peines je la retrouverai dans
quelques jours
le légiste lui vient d'être appelé sur
un double meurtre
vous vous habituez à la fréquentation
des morts des cadavres est-ce que on se
blinde c'est facile ont un pôle emploi
hier
malheureusement on finit par s'habituer
le plus important pour qu'on ne soit pas
affecté c'est de se concentrer sur les
indices qui pourront résoudre le meurtre
essayez de faire justice
chaque année il y a plus de meurtres à
Rio que dans toute la France à peu près
1500 une actualité macabre qui alimente
les médias
souvenez-vous de cette journaliste elle
travaille pour l'émission leaders sur
l'effet divers sida des alerta en
français la ville en alerte
la chaîne s'appelle Red et records voici
son siège
sida des alerta c'est 3 heures de faits
divers par jour dont une heure sur la
seule ville de Rio
au programme braquage meurtre et
gyrophare des images choc
des commentaires accrocheurs et des pics
d'audience à chaque numéro
j'ai rendez-vous avec le reporter star
de l'émission
Hernani Alves
le programme commence dans 30 minutes je
dois me speeder c'est ici qu'on prépare
le sujet il rentre tout juste de
tournage et doit monter son reportage
pour l'émission du soir
bonjour
ce matin
on a retrouvé deux voitures avec des
corps carbonisés quand tu vois un
cadavre là comme on a vu un corps
carbonisé est-ce que tu le montres à
l'antenne
la règle à la télé brésilienne c'est que
l'on ne peut pas montrer des images
violentes avant 22h alors on essaye de
montrer juste un bout une main ou alors
les vêtements mais jamais le corps
toi tu fais ça depuis combien de temps
moi j'ai commencé à l'âge de 18 ans j'ai
commencé à la radio parce qu'on n'a pas
besoin de diplôme universitaire et puis
j'ai continué à la télévision et tu
aimes ce job oh j'adore il y a de
l'action c'est dangereux mais bon on
prend des précautions c'est important de
montrer aux téléspectateurs ce qui se
passe dans la rue
[Musique]
je laisse Armani terminer son montage
mais je vais le retrouver demain il a
accepté de m'emmener sur le terrain
[Musique]
la nuit sera courte Hernani commence ses
journées à 4 heures du matin
Edson Edson tu peux lui demander de
sortir la voiture je finis un truc et on
s'en va pas de temps à perdre l'équipe
doit traverser toute la ville jusqu'à la
lointaine banlieue ouest ils sont
attendus au 27e bataillon de la police
militaire l'équivalent de notre
gendarmerie
ce matin une opération antidrogue est
prévue il est 5 heures Hernani se
présente à l'officier en charge
pas de chance une autre chaîne de
télévision a aussi été prévenu
une autre chaîne de télé
par balle qu'edouardo un vieux routier
de l'info a déjà porté sous d'autres
latitudes
ce sont les mêmes utilisés dans la
guerre en Irak tu vois
c'est aussi dangereux que l'Irak ici
tu as déjà vu tu connais la guerre il y
a des règles ici non la guerre on ne
tire pas sur les pompiers et sur les
ambulances ou les civils ici on tire sur
tout ce qui bouge et derrière
l'épaisseur tu vois
pas très maniable mais il n'y a pas le
choix
on dirait Robocop
tu vois ça
c'est l'équipement de la police
individuel ni de jumelles de visée
nocturne la police combat le crime avec
des moyens modestes
les forces spéciales américaines avec
toutes leurs technologies n'arrivent pas
à la hauteur de ces gars-là avec leur
simple fusil
[Musique]
démarrage entre autres pour les caméras
les 4 4 des chaînes de télévision
suivent le convoi
direction Antares une favela parmi les
plus dangereuses
il est 7 heures à l'avant le caméraman
tourne déjà images et son
itaire est de nouveau mobilisée pour une
opération contre le trafic de drogue
dans la zone ouest de Rio
suivez avec nous la police dans sa
progression dans la favela d'Antares
sportif
quitté leur voiture et commence leur
progression à pied il y a un policier
positionné à côté du poteau les autres
avancent à partir de maintenant Hernani
n'est pas en direct mais il fait comme
si il enregistre ses réactions en temps
réel
inconvénients il peut se tromper et mal
interprété ce qui se passe
avantage son reportage ce soir aura plus
de force
ils prennent le pont c'est un pont qui
est con vous voyez l'un des hommes en
position parce que les bandits peuvent
réagir
il est prêt à poster si les criminels
TER qui a l'air quand la police arrive
des feux d'artifice les trafiquants
avertissent de l'arrivée de la police
des feux d'artifice astucieux en voici
un corps chaud
dans la favela
il faut dire que les policiers n'ont pas
été très discrets ils ont sorti leur
vieux blindés dans ces ruelles un
éléphant n'aurait pas été plus visible
ceux qui tiennent le quartier se cache
mais pas de doute on est bien sur leur
territoire
CV
et là le fusil
et regarde un autre là
CV pour commando vermeilo commando rouge
l'un des trois gangs les plus puissants
de Rio
regroupement au milieu de la favela les
troupes se détendent les coups de feu
ont cessé
les familles peuvent sortir et emmener
les enfants à l'école
[Musique]
mais c'est un calme trompeur
c'est une rafale
le seul endroit sûr c'est par terre
mouvement de panique
le blindéfonce en direction des coups de
feu
ils nous ont tiré dessus ça fait comme
ça
les trafiquants resteront invisibles ils
n'ont rien à gagner à la frondement il
suffit d'attendre que la police se
replie pour reprendre leurs petites
affaires
bilan de l'opération deux gros sacs de
cocaïne saisies quand le suspect m'a vu
il a pris peur et pour celle léger il
s'est débarrassé de la radio et de la
drogue une capsule comme celle-là coûte
combien 15 real je pense soit 4 € le
gramme en Europe la cocaïne coûte en
moyenne 15 fois plus cher
dans cette guerre de la drogue la presse
se retrouve souvent prise entre deux
feux regarde ça
c'est le calibre le plus utilisé par les
criminels elle perce même les blindés
eux ils ont les armes et nous on a ça tu
vois
visent les caméras
il y a un an dans cette même favela
Hernani a vécu son expérience la plus
traumatisante
le cameraman Johnson Domingos de la
chaîne bandit est mort il couvrait une
opération policière dans la favela
d'Antarès quand il a reçu un tiers
mortel ce jour-là il couvre le même
genre d'opération avec son cameraman de
l'époque Jameson le même décor les mêmes
tirs les mêmes gilets par balles mais la
fin sera tragique
[Musique]
vient de recevoir une balle il va perdre
la vie
[Musique]
avec ce traumatisme mais rien ne
transparaît à l'antenne
la police
retour à la rédaction on sent que c'est
une machine bien huilée avec on va vite
le voir la pression permanente de
l'audience
incroyable au Brésil et les mesurée en
temps réel minute par minute
il est 12h59 l'audience de 12h57 il y a
seulement deux minutes vient d'arriver
en haut de l'écran en dessous les
minutes précédentes
chaque colonne représente une chaîne de
télévision réder et corde où je me
trouve et ses concurrents globaux SVT et
les autres
on va voir le résultat de notre travail
notre audimat était à 7.1
et là il monte jusqu'à 8.3
ils sont à moins de 5 avec les
opérations policiers on passe souvent
devant la chaîne concurrente la Globo
ils ont un style plus froid avec une
voix off nous on préfère le plan
séquence et on commente en direct ce qui
se passe et ça ça marche très bien
du coup il est temps d'aller dans le
sens du public d'allonger les sujets qui
marchent voire d'interrompre ceux qui
déplaisent
mais si le public décide à quoi peut
bien servir un rédacteur en chef
vous regardez l'audience minutes par
minute en temps réel est-ce que ça veut
dire que si un reportage est pas très
bon vous le jetez à la poubelle si un
sujet ne marche pas c'est sûr qu'on ne
le diffusera pas mais si l'audience est
bonne on laisse le sujet à l'antenne un
maximum de temps
par exemple on passe un sujet Elodie mat
monte alors on organise un plateau avec
le journaliste et on reprend en boucle
des images qui viennent de passer
quelles sont les histoires qui
intéressent le plus
les téléspectateurs
depuis toujours les fusillades ça fait
grimper le dimanche
et les descentes de police aussi
ce qui marche le mieux c'est les crimes
bizarres les meurtres passionnés
par exemple le cas du petit garçon
retrouvé mort dans le fleuve on ne sait
pas si c'est son beau-père qui l'a tué
ou non c'est un mystère si vous faites
une émission spéciale sur le crime sur
les faits divers c'est parce que ça fait
beaucoup d'audience
ici à Rio notre concurrence et la Globo
qui a une audience très élevée surtout
en soirée avec les feuilletons
alors nous on cible ceux qui ne
regardent pas les feuilletons qui
veulent des faits divers
et telenovelas peut être les deux phases
d'une même pièce les faits divers
sanglant pour ce que la violence fascine
les feuilletons à l'eau de rose pour
ceux qui veulent au contraire l'oublier
et puis pour tous le foot
au Brésil on y joue dès qu'on apprend à
marcher il y a des parties improvisées à
tous les coins de rue ou de plage
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que le secret d'un bon
footballeur
et puis connaître les règles c'est
fondamental ça
est-ce que ce sont des qualités
brésiliennes
la discipline et la tactique pas tant
que ça
mais la souplesse le fait de pouvoir
jongler avec les règles tout en les
respectant quand même dribbler ou faire
une passe différente ça oui quel est le
footballeur qui est votre idole au
Brésil
[Applaudissements]
Ronaldo
[Musique]
réveil matinal la police a convoqué les
médias pour un coup de filet une double
arrestation pour une affaire
d'escroquerie je retrouvais Nani le
reporter de faits divers
attention ça va se passer là ça s'ouvre
c'est bien vous qui habitez ici on a un
mandat d'arrêt contre vous
la police de communiquer elle est
chaînes ont besoin d'images du
gagnant-gagnant mais la police se fixe
quand même des limites on peut rentrer
les caméras ne passeront pas la porte du
suspect
côté journaliste Hernani prétend garder
son indépendance filmé de temps en temps
une arrestation spectacle n'empêcherait
pas d'être critique au reportage suivant
lorsque la critique est juste la police
ne peut pas se plaindre
nous on le dira
notre métier c'est l'investigation
soudain Hernani s’aperçoit de quelque
chose il en manque là non une équipe
concurrente vient de s'éclipser ils sont
peut-être partis ouvrir l'autre
arrestation c'est la compétition comme
on a deux caméras même j'en laisse un
sur la première arrestation pour avoir
les mêmes images que tout le monde et là
je cherche le petit truc qui fait la
différence petit problème Hernani et son
deuxième caméraman sont un peu perdus
bonjour s'il vous plaît vous connaissez
le parc Edison c'est de quel côté rue
son pied droit
vous êtes sûr merci
il y a plein de petits trucs le quartier
est très dense
[Musique]
c'est pas encore là mais c'est pas loin
juste à temps
[Musique]
parce que là tu imagines certains
l'oreille et pas nous il faut qu'on se
soucie de ça il faut qu'on ait minimum
le même bateau si jamais moi
l'homme au polo noir recadré par deux
policiers et bien le suspect arrêté
pourtant il n'est pas menotté
au Brésil quand la personne ne résiste
pas lors de son arrestation une loi
prévoit qu'il ne faut pas le menotter ce
soir sur toutes les chaînes la police
sera l'honneur mais peut-être pas la
présomption d'innocence message pas
d'impunité pour les malfrats la police
fait son travail Hernani lui aussi a
fait le sien il a ramené son lot
d'images du jour
retour au siège de la télévision
[Musique]
je vais sur le plateau de sida des
alerta l'émission de faits divers pour
laquelle travaillèrent Nanny
au moyen de la chaîne
on se croirait dans une cave et pourtant
il y a bien un studio au bout de ce
labyrinthe
en voici le présentateur oui Marcel
bonne soirée la police continue à
chercher partout dans la favela mais une
minute je vais écouter le
25 ans mais déjà Pro vous avez jamais de
prompteur
compte sont intradation parce qu'au
final c'est des interventions très
courtes pas besoin de compteurs
j'ai les éléments de l'histoire
qu'est-ce qui vous fait le plus plaisir
c'est quand vous avez réussi à lancer
une affaire qui trouve sa résolution
grâce à sudad alerta à ce que j'aime le
plus c'est quand la chaîne a une
exclusivité
que la record produit et réalisent
entièrement le sujet
ces histoires nous parviennent souvent
par dénonciation d'anonymes dans les
favelas de Rio et quand vous vous
promenez dans la rue les gens viennent
vers vous en vous demandant de résoudre
leurs problèmes ah oui si je fais mon
footing sur la plage à chaque maître il
va y avoir quelqu'un pour m'arrêter et
me dire tu sais j'ai un problème dans ma
communauté il y a plein de bandits armés
ou alors mon fils a disparu ou alors ça
fait un mois qu'on m'a coupé l'eau à la
maison
tous ces gens se rapprochent de nous
parce qu'on est la record une télé à
l'image du peuple avec son ADN ils
viennent nous voir comme un dernier
recours
voilà
vous êtes toujours le bienvenu
à l'étage d'en dessous un homme vient de
se présenter spontanément il veut
témoigner mais en restant anonyme il
suspecte la police de sa beauté une
enquête son père a été assassiné il y a
un mois et le suspect numéro 1 est
toujours en liberté
pourquoi vous les amis les proches de la
victime vous avez toujours peur de
montrer votre visage
je vais vous dire
c'est parce que le suspect du crime
habite près de chez nous et parce que
c'est un policier
encore une histoire qui implique la
police même si je le sais ces conditions
de travail sont difficiles
citoyen ordinaire avait commis le même
crime
il serait certainement derrière les
barreaux
et pas en liberté
c'est en allant à cette émission que
vous pensez déclencher un mouvement pour
qu'il y ait vraiment une enquête et pour
que ce policier soit jugé et financement
notre plus grande crainte c'est que la
fleur soit étouffer
mais si les médias on parle alors ils ne
pourront plus rien cacher la vérité avec
la trappe
dans
le temps en fait
on a plus confiance dans la presse que
dans les autorités
pour que leur cas gagne en visibilité
dans les médias les autorités agissent
surtout quand il s'agit de gens pauvres
des habitants des zones oubliées
la chaîne prend le témoignage très au
sérieux une vidéo à crédite la thèse
d'un meurtre de sang-froid commis par un
policier en civile regardez cet homme en
blanc qui s'avance c'est la future
victime il cherche le propriétaire d'une
voiture malgarée qui gêne la sienne
voici le propriétaire de la voiture avec
la casquette verte c'est un policier il
n'est pas en service
le Mont Blanc repasse suivi du policier
à casquette
le policier inspecte sa voiture et vient
s'expliquer avec le Mont Blanc
40 secondes plus tard il tire
panique dans le fast food sur ses images
ont devine seulement la scène un
mouvement brusque et puis le coup de feu
qui vous a donné ses images
la personne qui nous les a donnés veut
rester anonyme parce que le policier est
toujours en liberté
la police a d'autres vidéos mais on les
a pas sur les leurres on voit bien les
voitures et la rue on voit mieux ce qui
s'est passé
mais la journaliste ne baisse pas les
bras elle appelle la police en présence
du fils qui vient de la mettre sur la
terre au bout du fil le commissaire
chargé de l'enquête
abandon de l'enquête
ne va-t-on pas l'arrêter
armée
je peux confirmer cette info
il n'y aura pas d'arrestation
brésiliens estiment ne pas avoir de
leçon à recevoir
la semaine prochaine et vous le ferez
suivre au ministère public d'accord
c'est bien ça
merci désolé de vous avoir dérangé
pendant votre goûter au revoir
la police dit qu'elle a d'autres images
que nous ne possédons pas qui démontre
que le policier agit en situation de
légitime défense
ils disent qu'ils ne présenteront pas
ces images là et qu'il ne sera pas
accusé de missiles malgré le fait qu'il
est reconnu être l'auteur des tiers il
sera innocenté et quel est votre intime
conviction à vous
donc je serai curieuse de voir les
images de la police
6 mois plus tard la journaliste n'a
toujours pas pu visionner les images de
la police
l'enquête a conclu à la légitime défense
la victime laisse deux enfants et une
famille traumatisée par le sentiment
d'injustice mais tous les policiers sont
loin d'être comme ça à Rio
aujourd'hui ces jours de match au
maracanal le temple du football au
Brésil
il est 17h le coup d'envoi est à 19h
mais il y a déjà full aux abords du
stade
on a mobilisé les policiers à cheval
toujours dissuasifs c'est un match à
haut risque
l'une des quatre équipes de Rio va se de
gamma joue son maintien en première
division
cela serait furieux en cas de défaite
voici les jovens les ultras du club
[Applaudissements]
une vague impressionnante mais pour
l'instant Pacifique lui c'est Monsieur
sécurité
colonel fiorentini de la police
militaire à Rio c'est l'armée qui
encadre les matchs
à chaque match
l'objectif numéro un du colonel
fiorentini c'est que c'est jovens ne
croise pas le chemin des supporters
adverses
la vente d'alcool est interdite dans le
stade et aux alentours et pourtant la
bière coule à flot les supporters sont
venus avec leurs munitions
le colonel a reconnu l'un des leaders
des ultras
certains ont pris 6 mois de prison
maintenant on vous envoie directement
pour éviter les problèmes d'accord
menace à peine voilée police et justice
ont durci le ton ces derniers mois en
prévision du Mondial mais aussi en
réaction à plusieurs scandales deux
semaines après notre match Vasco de Gama
joue à l'extérieur 17e minute sur le
terrain et bataille rangée dans les
tribunes
mouvement de foule des deux camps pas un
seul policier pour s'interposer un
groupe s'acharne sur un homme au sol il
le piétine c'est un massacre un vrai
massacre
c'est terrible
[Applaudissements]
dit longues minutes plus tard les
policiers arrivent enfin
trop lents trop peu nombreux le bilan
sera lourd plusieurs dizaines de blessés
graves trois communs
ces images ont fait le tour du monde
mauvaise publicité pour le pays du
football
depuis c'est la police militaire qui
assure la sécurité dans les stades elle
fera peut-être baisser le nombre de
morts parmi les supporters il y en a eu
30 en 2013
au maracania stade mythique le connaît
fiorentini a déployé 650 hommes à
l'extérieur et à l'intérieur du stade
Peter ouverture des portes et palpation
obligatoire ni fumigène ni objet lourd
ou pointu
les supportrices n'échappent pas la
fouille
arrivé des joueurs
voici une vieille connaissance Johnny
nous l'attaquant star ancien pilier de
l'Olympique Lyonnais à 38 ans il n'a
toujours pas raccroché les crampons
pas de problème pour l'instant
ok super
allez venez
pour l'instant la situation est sous
contrôle le stade a été rénové et
sécurisé pour le Mondial d'abord avec
ses portiques renforcés pour filtrer et
ralentir
mais la modification la plus importante
est à l'intérieur
autorisation exceptionnelle du colonel
nous filmons sur la pelouse
la voici la principale amélioration
il n'y a plus que 70 000 places contre
110 000 avant les travaux et parfois 200
000 quand les spectateurs étaient debout
ça y est les tribunes sont pleines il
fait 30 degrés les supporters
[Applaudissements]
on a laissé tout un secteur vide comme
un pare-feu entre les deux gants ennemis
[Applaudissements]
sur plus de 50 mètres le coq de Vasco de
Gama déroule à un drapeau géant à tête
de mort
le match commence Vasco de Gama va-t-il
descendre en deuxième division
le colonel rejoint son poste
d'observation
combien de kilomètres vous faites par
match beaucoup
ouvre-moi la porte
ici c'est la salle de contrôle j'y ai
placé l'un de mes policiers avec
d'autres hommes qui travaillent ici
il faut montrer patte blanche
[Musique]
tout va bien oui ça va c'est un lieu
sensible le centre nerveux du Maracana
une grande surface vitrée mais c'est en
tournant le dos au terrain qu'on a la
meilleure vue un millier de caméras ont
été placés partout dans le stade
[Musique]
mais en fait je pourrais m'asseoir ici
et tout coordonner d'ici toutes les
entrées tous les secteurs tribunes et
terrains
physiquement c'est mon style de
commandement
mauvais scénario les visiteurs mènent au
score
est en train de perdre
alors là il faut qu'on soit plus
attentif
sur les supporters de Vasco de Gama il y
a un début de bousculade mais surprise
le conflit est à l'intérieur du même
camp
ce discute toujours entre il y en a
toujours un qui aime tel footballeur et
un autre qui ne l'aime pas il y en a qui
veulent que tel footballeur soit
remplacé par l'autre là ils sont tous du
même groupe de supporters
du groupe son rôle normalement c'est le
calmer les esprits
rien de grave pour cette fois au Mondial
ce sera plus sensible
avec les polices des autres pays elles
seront avec nous pendant la coupe du
monde pour donner un coup de main à la
police brésilienne
étranger mais la police française par
exemple oui
le représentant de la France va être ici
pour que collaborer avec nous comme le
représentant d'Angleterre d'Espagne ou
d'autres pays
dernier quart d'heure le match finit par
sourire à Vasco de Gama qui égalise à
deux partout
[Applaudissements]
joie des supporters le club évite pour
ce soir la relégation
avec le football les enjeux de sécurité
ne sont jamais loin des enjeux sportifs
que se passerait-il si un match du
Mondial devait dégénérer le Brésil s'y
prépare depuis 2008 déjà comment et bien
en reprenant le contrôle des favelas et
territoires de tous les trafics les
autorités n'ont pas les inné sur les
moyens hélicoptère blindé lance
roquettes des scènes de guerre civile en
pleine ville comme ici à Alemao en 2010
pas n'importe lesquels celle située à
proximité des stades de foot et des
zones touristiques
voici l'une de ces ravelas
au sud de Rio 30 000 habitants et une
vue imprenable sur la célèbre plage
d'Ipanema
avidigal lasso a été donné en 2011
depuis les narcotrafiquants ont
abandonné le terrain
place aux îlotiers comme pezenti 32 ans
[Musique]
il patrouille ici depuis deux ans avec
son jeune équipier Salazar 22 ans
si les îles portent quand même des
gilets barbare
personnelle du policier c'est un calibre
en tout trois armes de points chacun
soit une quarantaine de balles en cas de
fusillade
parfois vous avez des actes il y a de
l'agressivité de la part des habitants
quand vous vous promenez à pied
non c'est rare
ici la population nous a bien accepté
c'est très rare que ça arrive
et avec les trafiquants
les trafiquants le trafic intense a
disparu
la pacification a réussi
mais la réussite ne doit pas être totale
sinon pourquoi ça remet jusqu'aux dents
salut salut
bonjour
la favela offre l'un des plus beaux
points de vue sur la ville hier c'était
un coupe-gorge aujourd'hui c'est un
quartier un peu turbulent qui fait
saliver les promoteurs
bonjour
ambiance souriante au moins devant la
caméra vous trouvez que la cette
politique de pacification ça il y a des
bons résultats
qu'il y a moins de criminalités qu'avant
la police de proximité a bien travaillé
il reste des zones on n'est pas encore
présent mais on va s'y installer bientôt
ici depuis notre arrivée le quartier
c'est beaucoup amélioré tout est normal
le succès de la pacification repose sur
les enfants c'est un travail social en
fait c'est là dessus qu'on doit
s'engager j'y crois beaucoup
on va gagner
[Musique]
qu'en pensent les principaux intéressés
les habitants de la favela
je trouve ça cool ça nous a apporté plus
de tranquillité plus de sécurité
pour moi tout va bien pourquoi parce que
dès qu'il y a une embrouille les flics
arrivent sur place et puis calme tout le
monde et tout de suite après tout
redevient tranquille
dans les favelas reprises par l'armée
tout le monde n'est pas de cet avis les
habitants seraient parfois passer de la
loi de la mafia à l'arbitraire de la
police
qui va être la victoire de bien et le
mal parfois se confondent j'irai au
procès d'un ex policier accusé de
meurtre je verrai les ravages du crack
et je ferai la rencontre d'un pasteur
des baffes extrafiquant lui-même
j'assistrais à l'enterrement d'une
vieille dame victime d'une balle perdue
en pleine église
et je retrouverai Luciana l'inspectrice
de la brigade criminelle dans son
quotidien de drame et de sang
direction la rossinade une des plus
grandes favelas de Rio reprise par
l'armée en 2011 je prends une moto taxi
à Rio il n'y a pas plus rapide
mais il faut avoir le cœur bien accroché
mon chauffeur a tendance à doubler sans
visibilité
[Musique]
la course est un prix fixe l'équivalent
de 10 euros
dans la favela les portes n'ont pas de
numéro les rues pas de nom et elle a
rossigna la pente est raide
[Musique]
ce jeune homme me sert de guide sa
famille a été au cœur d'un scandale
national
Michel voici Michel la porte-parole du
clan merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
tout remonte au 14 juillet 2013 la
police de proximité de la rossigna
embarque un homme de 43 ans à Marilou
des Sousa c'est un maçon père de 6
enfants
les policiers veulent l'entendre
sa maison est juste en face d'un point
de trafic
il sait peut-être quelque chose
regardez sur ces images voici son
arrestation
à marildo ne reviendra pas il a été
torturé à mort pendant son
interrogatoire
cette disparition va choquer le Brésil
tout entier
les habitants de Rio manifeste
[Applaudissements]
dans la maison de marildo le deuil est
difficile pour ses enfants
le corps n'a pas été retrouvé
Michel la nièce du disparu donne la
morale de l'histoire
avant il y avait un pouvoir le pouvoir
parallèle on savait malheureusement
qu'ils avaient leurs règles et que si on
voulait bien vivre dans la communauté il
fallait obéir à ses règles mais ce n'est
plus comme ça aujourd'hui il y a le
pouvoir parallèle et aussi le pouvoir de
la police et on doit faire avec les deux
ici dans notre communauté depuis
l'arrivée de la police de proximité nos
garçons sont humiliés nos filles
insultaient
ici l'arrivée de ces policiers n'a pas
du tout amélioré notre vie au contraire
depuis mon arrivée c'est le 3e meurtre
imputé à la police à Rio il faut parfois
savoir se méfier des uniformes
pourtant c'est bien une enquête de
police qui a fait éclater la vérité sur
la disparition d'amarelledo
d'une femme obstinée une femme
commissaire qui a eu le cran de désigner
les coupables 13 policiers tous des
hommes
Hélène suto
une héroïne nationale
alors là on rentre dans votre bureau
là c'est la copie de l'enquête ce sont
12 volumes d'enquête
[Musique]
dans ce cas c'était 1200 heures de
transcription des coups de téléphoniques
on est allé à la Rossini à 33 fois
il y a eu deux reconstitutions et 133
auditions
et combien de temps en tout pour
l'enquête
à partir du moment où elle nous a été
confiée elle a duré 61 jours sans
interruption samedi dimanche compris de
8h du matin jusqu'à 23h en mettant en
prison 13 membres de l'UPP est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment de rendre service
à la police
oui
c'est inadmissible aujourd'hui de
vouloir obtenir des infos avec des
pratiques archaïques
c'est inadmissible dans un état
démocratique
et est-ce que vous avez été menacé
pendant votre enquête c'est ce que vous
avez des menaces de mort par exemple
non pas du tout
est-ce que vous diriez que c'était que
c'est la plus belle enquête de votre vie
oui c'est l'enquête de ma vie pour la
répercussion qu'elle a eu mais ce n'est
pas ça qui me rend heureuse ce qui me
rend heureux c'est de voir que le
résultat de mon travail a permis de
connaître la vérité
les 13 policiers attendent leur procès
derrière les barreaux peut-être vont-ils
révéler ce qu'ils ont fait du corps à
marildo et cette enquête s'ouvre à
l'honneur de la police
[Musique]
ariolet crime sont parfois faciles à
élucider mais très souvent né de la
cocaïne
c'est le quotidien de la brigade
criminelle
[Musique]
je retrouve Luciana l'inspectrice
rencontrait au début de mon séjour
aujourd'hui elle a été appelée sur un
drame familial voici des parents de la
victime
c'était ma fille
et vous êtes le père
leur fille venu chez eux avec ses deux
enfants un garçon de 15 ans et un bébé
de 9 mois
[Musique]
voici le meurtrier c'est le père des
enfants il prenait de la drogue et se
montrait souvent violent avec son
ex-femme
c'est à cause des drogues elle aussi
consommée de la drogue à cause de ça
elle revenait souvent chez lui il
passait la chercher et à l'arrivait tout
de suite
les parents ont demandé à voir le corps
de leur fille Luciana va trouver les
mots pour refuser
[Musique]
toute scène de crimes est une scène
traumatique pensez à votre fille comme
elle était avant d'accord c'est ce que
je lui ai dit
c'est ce que vous devez faire dans cette
situation
cet adolescent est le fils de la victime
visage impassible comme s'il ne
comprenait pas encore ce qui vient de se
passer
donc vous êtes la mère de l'accusé non
non ce n'est pas moi sa maman est à
l'intérieur moi je suis la marraine de
la mort
la mère du meurtrier elle aurait parlé à
son fils juste après le drame
il est venu vous voir en disant quoi
exactement il est arrivé avec des
vêtements ensemble il me les a donnés
parce que c'est nous qui l'avons leurs
vêtements ici il est arrivé avec la
petite il m'a aidé avec le linge puis il
m'a dit j'ai détruit ma vie elle m'a
trompé il m'a juste dit ça et il est
parti où je ne sais pas
calmez-vous calmez-vous
voici la scène de crime la chambre à
coucher
une violente dispute éclate vers 3h du
matin entre les deux
l'homme saisit un couteau et frappe
[Musique]
sur le téléviseur une ligne de coque
c'est tout ce qui reste de ces deux
tubes vides le couple était sous
l'emprise de la drogue
[Musique]
Luciana travaille à la brigade
criminelle depuis 4 ans déjà avec le
temps elle s'est endurcie et pourtant
dans l'histoire je le ressens un peu
quand même
je le sens un peu même si j'essaye de
garder mon calme pour pouvoir me
concentrer sur l'enquête
pour un jeune garçon de 15 ans et un
bébé de 9 mois ne plus avoir leur maman
c'est c'est une tragédie
c'est terrible
[Applaudissements]
le corps est emmené par les employés de
la mort sous le regard des parents et
des proches
la mère du meurtrier est au plus mal sa
famille la soutient jusqu'à la voiture
de police
Luciana va la conduire au commissariat
pour témoigner
le reste de l'équipe part sur une autre
scène de crime toute proche
regarde
[__] je le savais je le savais une
première rafale
avertissement la police vient d'entrée
sur le territoire d'un gang
particulièrement violent
et ce n'était pas des tirs en l'air
ça va tirer
c'est la favela du n'importe quoi ici
c'est toujours comme ça
ils viennent de nous tirer dessus
[Musique]
les policiers se mettent à couverts
comme des soldats en terrain ennemis
[Musique]
voilà ce qu'ils sont venus chercher le
corps sans vie d'un garçon de 18 ans tué
d'une balle dans la tête c'est un
règlement de compte loi du silence
personne n'a rien vu ce crime là restera
sûrement impuni
[Musique]
je m'octroie un instant de pause une
visite au fameux Pain de Sucre ce python
rocheux qui surplombe la ville vu d'ici
Rio paraît calme et pourtant de près la
violence des formes la carte postale
[Musique]
sur la plage les touristes ne se rendent
compte de rien dans les beaux quartiers
d'ailleurs les risques d'agression sont
minimes
[Musique]
les faits divers partent souvent des
favelas il se termine toujours au
tribunal de Rio
la première chambre criminelle voit
passer les affaires les plus graves
kidnapping viol meurtre c'est le
président Fabio uchua qui siège
un juge réputé sévère mais juste
[Musique]
l'audience du jour n'est pas un procès
c'est la dernière étape de l'enquête le
président uchoa a réuni tous les
protagonistes pour décider si le dossier
mérite d'aller jusqu'au procès
l'accusé est présent
il est suspecté de meurtre derrière lui
son avocat il s'exprimeront plus tard
d'abord les témoins la procureur mène
d'interrogation
[Musique]
il voulait me taper il donnait des coups
sur le capot et les vitres de la voiture
le meurtrier présumé s'avance c'est un
commerçant il aurait abattu l'un des
jeunes qui squatait se droguer devant
son magasin
vous souhaitez vous exprimer sur l'effet
ou vous préférez vous taire où et
j'accepte le soir du crime les jeunes
font du bruit dans la rue il s'amusent à
casser des bouteilles excéder le
commerçant sort de chez lui une bagarre
commence
pourquoi avez-vous tiré sur la victime
se diriger vers moi
et puis il a commencé à m'insulter à me
traiter de tous les noms puis trois de
ses amis montant cerclé par derrière au
moment où il m'a sauté
je me suis mis à l'insulter aussi je lui
ai dit c'est toi qui ne respecte
personne en jetant des pierres chez les
gens
il est devenu violent j'ai eu peur
sur moi il était à 30 cm c'était très
rapide il était menaçant et avec quelque
chose sous son t-shirt qui était noir ou
gris
j'ai cru qu'il allait sortir quelque
chose en dessous
immédiatement j'ai sorti mon arme et
j'ai tiré
je ne sais pas dans quelle direction
mais j'ai tiré je ne sais pas où elle a
touché je ne sais pas
légitime défense ou pas sa vie a basculé
en quelques secondes
c'est une journée que je voudrais
effacer de ma vie
je ne me serais jamais réveillé ce
jour-là
j'aurais dû faire une sieste avec ma
fille
je regrettement ce jour-là
si seulement ça s'était passé autrement
le ministère public veut-il poser une
question oui monsieur le juge la parole
est à vous
les faits sont constitués le juge va
renvoyer au procès les jurés vont-ils
accorder des circonstances atténuantes
réponse dans trois mois
juge Fabio la plupart du temps vous avez
à juger des homides là vous l'avez fait
toute la journée
comment vous expliquer qu'au Brésil il y
a 25 fois plus d'homicide en pourcentage
réel en France par exemple
un problème c'est un problème culturel
il y a beaucoup d'homicides et notamment
dans les régions les plus pauvres la
violence est plus forte
[Musique]
plus ils sont violents et les
comportements peuvent être plus
agressifs
parallèlement à tout ça une grande
partie des homicides qui ont lieu à Rio
sont aujourd'hui commis par des groupes
tels que les narcos ou les milices
ce sont eux les principaux responsables
aujourd'hui de cette violence
les milices voici un nouvel acteur dans
le paysage criminel
eux restent toujours invisible ancien
policier ou militaire ils sont passés du
côté obscur
dans les favelas il propose la sécurité
contre de l'argent
direction la carabine hier une favela
ultra dangereuse aujourd'hui un quartier
presque calme la milice a expulsé les
trafiquants de drogue mais tout a un
prix
nous suivons une équipe de télévision de
raie des records il y a eu ce matin un
incendie criminel les camions d'un
marchand de matériaux ont brûlé le voici
à gauche de l'écran
aujourd'hui c'est 25 employés sont au
chômage technique impossible de livrer
le sable ou les pierres sur les
chantiers
[Musique]
cette nuit vers 4h du matin les trois
camions de l'entreprise ont pris feu le
patron avait dit non aux raquettes de la
milice
je veux travailler mais j'ai peur
je veux que la police puisse garantir ma
sécurité
que je puisse venir travailler sans peur
[Applaudissements]
même mon frère a peur on a tous peur
même mes deux enfants qui travaillent
avec moi ont peur
si le quartier est tenu par la milice tu
dois donner un pourcentage de tes
revenus pour assurer ta sécurité
et
c'est fini pour toi
même les journalistes doivent respecter
les règles
ils savent déjà que nous sommes ici
[Applaudissements]
on ne serait pas là
vous les avez prévenu
pas facile pour un journaliste de
reconnaître qu'il a besoin d'une
autorisation de criminel pour faire son
métier
[Musique]
merci Ciao
pour un policier c'est encore plus
compliqué la milice est un sujet tabou
puisque ce sont souvent d'anciens flics
ou militaires qui sont derrière
[Musique]
de la ministre le commissaire du
quartier ne veut pas entendre parler il
refuse toute une interview et préfère
mettre l'incendie des camions sur le dos
des trafiquants de drogue
retour au tribunal toujours avec le juge
outshua mais cette fois pour un vrai
procès un membre de la milice justement
il est accusé de meurtre c'est l'heure
du verdict
vous n'êtes pas l'auteur de ce meurtre
vous avez été jugé non coupable
et aujourd'hui
n'a pas retenu la culpabilité pour ce
meurtre c'est un non-lieu
joie de sa femme derrière la vitre mais
l'homme ne repart pas libre il est
accusé d'autres meurtre
le juge Fabio sait que ce genre de
dossier peut se terminer par un non-lieu
normanation est difficile car les
témoins au début se rendent spontanément
au commissariat et donne tous les
détails de ce qui s'est passé
mais ensuite le temps passe et avec
toutes les pressions qu'il subissent la
peur grandit
et ils essayent de s'éloigner de leur
premier témoignages
il se contredise et finissent par nier
ce qu'ils ont dit au départ
c'est très fréquent
la milice est puissante la juge Patricia
azzoli était son ennemi personnel une
incorruptible qui allait boucler une
enquête d'envergure
la voici qui rentre chez elle en voiture
le 12 août 2011
elle n'a plus qu'une heure à vivre
[Musique]
des tueurs la suivent à moto
ils vont l'exécuter de 21 balles
[Musique]
c'est le jugeoutchoua qui va reprendre
le flambeau
il continuera le travail de sa collègue
et fera même condamner ses assassins
tous des policiers
[Musique]
un autre juge va le remplacer
immédiatement et va continuer son
travail
parce qu'un procès s'appuie sur un
dossier sur des preuves et sur la force
de la loi le juge
peu importe le juge la loi est la même
le jujua à la fois mais comment lutter
contre le crime dans une société aussi
inégalitaire
le Brésil compte plus de milliardaires
en dollars que la France ou la
Grande-Bretagne
[Musique]
cet après-midi je suis l'invité de
Ricardo Riquet
un abord chaleureux il me reçoit en
short et polo
si je sors maintenant si quelqu'un veut
me parler tu lui dis qu'on m'appelle sur
mon portable oui messieurs
c'est un homme très riche
personnel de maison et vu plongeante sur
la bellerie son appartement fait 400
mètres carrés et vaut plus de 4 millions
d'euros au prix du marché à 65 ans
passés ricardo a pris sa retraite il
gère aujourd'hui sa fortune et son petit
empire il possède 26 centres commerciaux
à travers tout le pays
la météo est au beau fixe 38 degrés à
l'ombre direction la plage
à l'arrière sa fille Rebecca 13 ans avec
une amie
il y a beaucoup de Porsche Cayenne à Rio
mais celle de Ricardo est blindée
comptez 30000 euros supplémentaires
il valait mieux la blinder
parce que c'était dangereux
il y avait des enlèvements des tirs
beaucoup de membres de ma famille quand
ils sortaient prenait un garde du corps
mais aujourd'hui c'est terminé il n'y a
plus rien
aujourd'hui est la même qu'à Londres à
New York ou Paris
tout est normal les chiffres sont faux
c'est 25 fois plus mais c'est déjà
beaucoup mieux qu'il y a 5 ans
je n'ai pas peur quand je marche dans la
rue le problème c'est les gens qui
attirent l'attention qui portent des
montres cher qui ont des voitures chères
mais moi ça va
tu t'habilles normalement ça craint pas
[Musique]
les plages préférées de Ricardo ne sont
accessibles que par la mer
je vais prendre mon bateau Rebecca
votre nom monsieur je m'appelle Ricardo
Riquet
marina privée et sécurisée
voici le yacht baptisé au nom de sa
fille Rebecca 26 mètres et tout le
confort à bord
[Musique]
ici 14-13 le skipper est salarié à temps
plein comme les deux autres membres
d'équipage
Marco Marco oui monsieur comment il
s'appelle la plage où on peut se baigner
Adam et Eve là on peut
on peut y aller oui on peut essayer
allez la première
allez on y va
[Musique]
mais ce yacht n'est pas le jouet le plus
cher de Ricardo
j'ai un lead jet ça c'est mon jouet le
plus cher 4 millions d'euros pour cet
avion privé pour les trajets urbains
ricardo a aussi son propre hélicoptère
l'hélicoptère c'est pas cher pour celui
qui a de l'argent ça vaut la peine pour
pouvoir aller à la plage et au travail
en évitant les bouchons ça vaut vraiment
le coup
qu'est-ce que tu nous fais à manger
depuis que la criminalité a baissé tout
le monde dit que Rio c'est la plus belle
ville du monde
tout le monde le dit
c'est vrai Rio est magnifique et les
touristes ont presque rien à craindre
pour les riches carioca Rio est un
paradis pour les pauvres c'est une ville
moins prévisible où le pire peut
toujours vous surprendre
Teresa Santos avait 77 ans elle est
morte en sortant de la messe sur le
parvis de l'église fauché par une balle
perdue
[Musique]
dehors la presse est là dans ce pays
très religieux sortir une arme devant la
maison de Dieu et sacrilège nous
retrouvons Eduardo le journaliste
bourlingueur des favelas aujourd'hui il
est très en colère
[Musique]
au moment du carnaval ou quand Neymar
marque un but
et que les idiots crient Brésil Brésil
je ne crie pas vive le Brésil parce que
j'ai honte et que je ne sais pas si je
rentrerai vivant à chaque fois que je
sors dans la rue
il y a plus de Brésiliens morts ici que
dans la guerre au Moyen-Orient
le lendemain de la cérémonie je
rencontre la famille de la défunt dans
une église transformée en fournaise
est-ce que vous avez interrogé Dieu et
vous lui avez dit pourquoi tu as permis
que ma mère soit tuée devant ton Église
c'est sa volonté que sa volonté soit
faite les avantages même si sa volonté
nous fait souffrir mais au-dessus tout
c'est sa volonté qui doit l'emporter
vous êtes choqués qu'on puisse tirer
devant une église
au Brésil les gens sont en train de
perdre leur valeur morale familiale et
aussi la valeur de la vie humaine
c'est un signe d'échec pour tout le pays
qu'est-ce que il faudrait pour que vous
soyez en paix maintenant avec ce drame
est-ce qu'il faudrait que l'homme qui a
tiré sur votre maman soit punie ou alors
est-ce que vous êtes capable de
pardonner dans vos prières de l'associer
à votre maman
je suis réconfortée parce que je sais
qu'elle reste avec nous et qu'elle est
entrée dans la maison du père
quant à la justice des hommes je ne sais
pas si elle ira au bout mais je sais que
la justice divine ne faillit jamais je
sais que tout ça est difficile pour vous
vous pouvez traduire mais je vous
remercie beaucoup de nous avoir parlé
[Musique]
le Christ veille sur la ville
où qu'on soit il suffit de lever la tête
pour se souvenir de cette promesse une
vie meilleure et possible
certains à Rio n'ont pas eu la passer en
attente
ils ont choisi les paradis artificiels
et pour eux c'est l'enfer sur terre
ils vivent dans la rue fume du CRAC
et ont oublié leur âge depuis longtemps
c'est pas la même sensation qu'hier
ça fait longtemps que je vis ici
possible de s'approcher des trafiquants
de drogue et de les filmer trop
dangereux
quelqu'un en ville s'est donné pour
mission de sauver ses brebis égarés
le pasteur John
il est lui-même ancien toxicoman
aujourd'hui il a une fois soulevé les
montagnes
et des friches
c'était une vieille maison
et c'est nous qui avons construit tout
ça
ici les logements et voici les
pensionnaires
certains sont couchés
[Musique]
de toutes sortes ici on est là pour se
reconstruire
un grand dortoir avec des paillasses
bricolés ici on vit sous le regard de
l'autre certains sont là depuis des
années
est-ce qu'il y en a un qui est assez
plusieurs
mois ou plusieurs années en prison
combien de temps es-tu resté en prison
20 ans et pourquoi as-tu été condamné
pour trafic de drogue international
trafic de drogue international mais même
moi je ne savais pas vous ne saviez pas
non je ne savais pas pardonnez-moi mon
pasteur vous allez mettre dehors je vais
te mettre en prison
tous ces hommes-là croient en Dieu et
croient en Jésus oui tout son croyant
absolument
ici le sevrage se fait sans médicaments
regardez la Bible
est-ce que tout le monde pense que Jésus
va les sauver que Dieu va les sauver de
la drogue
absolument il les a sauvés déjà
aujourd'hui je ne possédais rien mais
j'ai tout parce que j'ai trouvé un Dieu
qui m'a tout donné dans la vie
aujourd'hui Alvaro et comacro à la
Parole de Dieu
de Dieu et non celle des hommes
il nous transmet le Dieu qui habite en
lui
il est un homme comment vous expliquer
un homme qui marche et il a une attitude
d'homme de Dieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez vous parlez comme un pasteur
vous voulez pas devenir passeur comme
Johnny
si Dieu le veut merci
les hommes qui sont ici ont tous une
histoire
viens ici alex
lui il n'a pas eu de problème
il n'a pas été dans les trafics ni dans
la drogue
et lui c'est arrivé quand il était petit
raconte-nous ce que tu as vu j'ai vu mon
père tu es ma mère il a vu son père tu
es sa mère il était encore petit et il a
fallu qu'il quitte sa maison
depuis vivait dans les rues
notre équipe qui prêchait l'Évangile la
trouver sous un pont en Espagne
il vivait en mendiant quel âge a-t-il
c'est moi son père
et dans cette famille tout commence et
tout finit par des prier
[Applaudissements]
être délivré de la drogue de la pauvreté
ou de la violence qui vont de pair
chaque jour des millions de prière monde
des favelas ou des quartiers chics de
Rio
et il se crée sans cesse de nouvelles
églises
bienvenue à l'église christique de la
Terre Promise une église protestante
fondée il y a un an seulement
[Musique]
c'est la messe du dimanche et voici la
fondatrice
Christelle Bianco
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alléluia
Jésus est mort la Parole de Dieu elle
est vivante
[Musique]
avant d'être pasteur Christelle était
actrice elle jouait dans les telenovelas
c'était la femme de Ricardo le
multimillionnaire
de son ancienne vie et la garder
quelques bijoux de prix et un certain
sens de la mise en scène
aujourd'hui Christelle répond à la bonne
parole dans un quartier populaire
ici il y a du chômage de la violence et
une forte demande d'espoir
avec ses soldats de Dieu elle a
rendez-vous chez cet homme qui souffre
d'une grave nécrose des jambes
le pouvoir de l'Esprit Saint est dans ma
vie
le sang du Seigneur a été versé dans ma
grâce à Dieu grâce à Dieu grâce à Dieu
grâce à Dieu
nous travaillons avec le royaume
spirituel
regardez tout ça c'est comme des
brûlures
c'est un mâle qui lui vient du royaume
spirituel c'est quelque chose de
diabolique dans sa vie et pour ça la
médecine a des limites vous vous sentez
mieux après la prière et comment ça
soulage avant je me sentais vous vous
sentiez angoissé
oui
vous étiez angoissé
et on sait que Dieu est puissant
alors quand le groupe intervient ça fait
du bien
vous avez l'argent pour payer l'hôpital
j'ai une pension modeste et je n'ai pas
d'argent pour payer mes soins
[Musique]
prochainement chez un voisin qui se
plaint d'étrange maux de tête Christelle
va le désenvoûter du moins l'expertise
vous avez de l'hypertension vous ne vous
sentez pas bien un peu d'huile rituel
tu as les mains gelées et la séance
commence
Raphaël je vais prier et tu n'arrêtes
pas de me regarder il y a un gitan qui
perturbe ta vie
c'est un démon qui veut t'amener dans
des endroits terribles il te poursuit
je vais prier et tu me regardes ok
veulent prendre la vie de cet homme et
maintenant que viennent l'Esprit Saint
Seigneur la vie de cet homme et protéger
le des flèches lancées contre lui au nom
de Jésus le Seigneur
protège cet homme avec un mur de pierre
accepte cet homme comme guerrier de Dieu
père nous sommes rentrés dans cette
maison et vous aussi Seigneur rentrez
avec nous
ta parole et l'onction du Saint-Esprit
que toutes ces familles soient sauve
Père au nom de Jésus chasse tout mauvais
esprit lancé contre cette famille
qu'à partir de maintenant cet homme soit
libéré
Père au nom de Jésus nous vous demandons
de sauver cette famille Seigneur au nom
de Jésus je t'implore
au nom de Jésus et du Saint-Esprit au
nom du Père et du Saint-Esprit AMEN
[Applaudissements]
er
le bouche à oreille a fonctionné dans la
rue les candidats à la bénédiction
commencent à affluer des familles et des
enfants eux ne demandent pas la santé
mais la sécurité
sanguinaire puisse venir toucher ses
enfants
au nom de Jésus-Christ
Dieu protège-les
des balles perdues et ne les laissez pas
dévier du bon chemin
pour l'instant Christelle n'a qu'une
centaine de fidèles mais Dieu a pour
elle de grands dessins
Yodé riches et des politiciens
je vois l'injustice tous les jours de ma
vie
et je fais tout ça peut-être pour ne pas
devenir quelqu'un d'amer
je cherche Dieu et la justice divine
parce que la justice d'ici-bas elle est
horrible
[Musique]
mon séjour se termine à Rio j'aurais vu
beaucoup de sang mais aussi beaucoup
d'énergie et d'espoir
avant de partir je passe une dernière
fois au Maracana c'est là que ce jour à
la finale du Mondial le 13 juillet à 16h
heure locale
d'ici là Rio n'en aura pas fini avec le
crime et la violence
mais c'est un but à porter des cariocas
rien n'est impossible quand on joue
collectif